herzlich willkommen im
2013 auch in dieses neue jahr starten
wir mit einem kulturplatz extra ich lebe
in der schweiz und habe einen job damit
gehöre ich zu den delegierten unter der
helvetischen käseglocke während
rundherum die schuldenkrise ihren tribut
fordern der blick über die grenze löst
ein mulmiges gefühl aus und hat mich
dazu bewogen den rucksack zu packen um
eine besondere reise zu tun mein ziel
heißt spanien das land in dem derzeit
jeder vierte ohne job auskommen muss die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit beträgt sogar
mehr als 50 prozent ich selber bin 31
und frage mich wie meine generation
irgendwo zwischen ausbildungsende und
familienplanung mit dieser krise umgeht
ausgebremst in einer lebensphase in der
man doch eigentlich so richtig
durchstarten möchte es ist auch die rede
von einer verlorenen generation
erstes etappenziel
barcelona
eine fahrt durch die nacht in ein land
aus dem uns in letzter zeit negative
schlagzeilen erreichen die eu
schuldenkrise hat spanien fest im griff
ich bin verabredet mit den gut
ausgebildeten meiner generation
sie haben studiert sprechen mehrere
sprachen sind flexibel innovativ und
motiviert aber eine echte perspektive
haben sie nicht
concia barcelona die perle kataloniens
auch in der wirtschaftlich stärksten
region spaniens kämpfen die menschen
auch hier herrscht die krise jeden tag
aufs neue die schlagzeilen
als erstes fahre ich etwas raus aus der
stadt in den vorort wie lassa thema
hier versuche ich nur eine übersetzerin
für deutsch und spanisch die 26-jährige
empfängt mich mit spanischer
herzlichkeit
nur er hat die studiums summa cum laude
abgeschlossen und war zwei jahre in
deutschland zurück in spanien machte sie
sich selbstständig zunächst sehr
erfolgreich doch seit letzten sommer
geht es bergab
leider bekommen ich musste sogar manche
abgeben und dann plötzlich habe ich eine
andere und ja ich habe angst gekriegt
angst er weil ich weiss nicht wie jetzt
sichern musikern wird ja
hast du immer noch angst oder war es
mehr als am anfang eine situation und
jetzt also am anfang hatte ich noch die
hoffnung ja es wird einen monat soda
oder vielleicht im sommer gibt es nicht
so viel los aber ja ich hatte den
nächsten monate auch nichts bekommen und
jetzt wohnst du hier wieder bei deinen
eltern ja wie ist das für dich mit 26 ja
ich würde gerne alleine wohnen oder in
einem wg weil ich auch schon mal die
montage aber jetzt kann ich mir das
nicht leicht nun wirklich keine
morgen wieder bei mama und papa stelle
ich mir nicht einfach vor
auf dem örtlichen markt kaufen wir fürs
abendessen ein
meine mutter die bereits nehmen vieles
mit humor auf die letzten jobs von nuria
bei denen sie es sich nicht leisten
konnte wählerisch zu sein
habe ich die sind granit aktionen das
übersetzung das war einerseits waren der
doku sowie der igel markt fassen was und
ich habe auch das ist ein bisschen
komisch klingen kann ich habe auch herrn
pornofilme übersetzt
das gemacht muss man da viel übersetzen
ja mehr als ich gedacht habe
also die kartoffeln die kommen übrigens
aus den familiengarten selbstversorgung
ist wichtiger geworden erzählt nuria
auch ihr freund paul kommt zum essen er
hat seinen job im november verloren
hat sich das familienleben auch ein
bisschen verändert drückt man wieder
näher ist das soziale irgendwie wichtige
ja weil jetzt ist das auch so dass die
eltern wieder
tochter oder die sonne halfen müssen
viele fans herum nach hause oder viele
omas angeben dass es unseren
enkelkindern
also es gibt jetzt diese solidarität das
war immer so weil eine familie ist eine
familie aber man braucht das jetzt auch
mehr und auch wenn man so allein ist
dann ist es wichtig dass die freunde und
die familie und so larsen
und wie ist das für sie das nur wieder
zu hause ist
nuria wird hier immer einen platz haben
weil wir eine familie sind
aber ich würde mich freuen wenn sie eine
eigene wohnung hätte ich einen job hätte
und wirtschaftlich unabhängig wäre
wo der staat versagt rückt die familie
stärker in den vordergrund
das wird mir heute abend deutlich
bewusst
am nächsten tag beim spaziergang durch
barcelona mir fallen die vielen flecken
auf
der weißen sternen auf blauem
hintergrund ist ein politisches
statement für einen eigenen unabhängigen
staat viele katalanen befürchten nämlich
für die schulden rest spaniens aufkommen
zu müssen
im café treffen wir nur als freunde sie
gehören zur best ausgebildeten
generation spaniens alle um die 30 alle
unzufrieden mit ihrer beruflichen
situation
ich habe das lehrer diplom für
katalonien jetzt gibt es für uns keine
arbeit mehr ich weiß nicht wann ich eine
stelle bekommen werde
ich bin umweltingenieur das ist
verbunden mit dem bauwesen und wegen der
immobilienblase geplatzt ist gibt es
kein job für die leute die das fach
studiert haben wirklich für niemanden
alle die ich kenne mussten ins ausland
gehen oder sie haben gerade ihren job
verloren
früher trafen sich die freunde einmal
wöchentlich zum essen das krisen budget
reicht gerade noch für ein getränk
ich habe ein studium abgeschlossen mit
guten ergebnissen
ich wollte in meinem bereich arbeiten
aber ich kann nicht jetzt bin ich spital
helfer und trage menschen zum röttgen
jetzt sollten wir unternehmen gründen
oder unternehmen ins land reinholen die
von unserem ingenieurswissen profitieren
kann
ich sitze mit gleichaltrigen am tisch
die gerne etwas bewegen würden aber das
vertrauen in den staat das haben sie
völlig verloren
spaniens politiker haben versagt aber
keiner tritt zurück keiner
gefragt wir haben die nase voll von
allen politikern von den katalanischen
wie auch für den spanischen
was könnt ihr denn tun würdet ihr am
liebsten alle politiker aus wechseln
könnt ihr überhaupt was ändern
wir haben unsere familien wir verlassen
uns weiter auf sie das einzige was wir
erwarten können ist zu überleben gerade
so über die runden zu kommen
was ich bisher gehört habe lässt mich so
schnell nicht los
der stadt am meer sind die probleme auf
den ersten blick nicht anzusehen und
doch eine ganze generation bangt um ihre
zukunft was passiert mit diesem land
die reise geht weiter nach madrid die
hauptstadt gilt als zentrum der
spanischen krise
wir haben nur er gebeten mit zu kommen
um uns beim übersetzen zu helfen und sie
will mehr in madrid auch ihre ältere
schwester ruth vorstellen
gut ist 28 sie hat ihre stelle in einer
pr-agentur verloren und konzentriert
sich jetzt auf eine zweite ausbildung
zur fotografin und grafikdesignerin
mit ihrer kamera dokumentiert sie ihren
blick auf die krise
seit wann bist du arbeitslos seit juni
aber ich bin auch erleichtert
erleichtert
weil ich viel zu viel gearbeitet habe
und dabei sehr wenig verdient habe
ich habe von montag bis samstag manchmal
zwölf stunden am stück gearbeitet
gegessen habe ich vor dem computer jetzt
nutze ich meine arbeitslosigkeit um mich
beruflich neu zu orientieren das zu tun
was ich schon immer tun wollte
in roths büro wurden immer mehr leute
entlassen sie dir eine leitende funktion
hatte musste noch mehr arbeiten gut war
komplett erschöpft die arbeitslosigkeit
ein aufatmen
was ist hier los
hier stehen die schlange weil da eines
der wichtigsten verkaufslokal für
lotterielose ist
dieses jahr kaufen die leute mehr lose
wegen der krise weil sie vom reichtum
träumen
ich mache von da hinten ein foto
wer kunden die spanische hauptstadt auf
eigene faust madrid das politische und
kulturelle zentrum spaniens
madrid die stadt wo die hoffnungen auf
eine rosige zukunft
zerplatzen puerta del sol dieser platz
ist die wiege der prozess bewegung 15 m
die sogenannten empörten trafen sich am
15 mai 2011 um gegen die regierung zu
protestieren
seitdem fliegt der überwachungs
helikopter der polizei
auch die spanischen medien ringen ums
überleben die stolze lb ist hat ein
drittel der belegschaft entlassen
die wirtschaftskrise verfolgt auch die
kulturbranche die mehrwertsteuer wurde
bei kino- konzert- und theatertickets
von 8 auf 21 prozent angehoben und ist
heute eine der höchsten europas wer
leistet sich da noch ein kinoticket
gleichzeitig wird gnadenlos gespart das
kulturministerium kürzt die subventionen
für das material opern aus der atom
reihe um ein drittel aus geldmangel
fallen produktion aus
täglich demonstrieren die menschen in
madrid diese zombies zum beispiel die
protestieren gegen die streichung der
musikstunden an öffentlichen schulen
bildung und kultur die klassischen
ersten sparopfer auch hier in spanien
sie wollen uns die kunst wegnehmen aber
die kunst wird niemals sterben
die krise scheint auch kreatives
potenzial freizusetzen
der neueste trend das mikro theater hier
wird jede viertelstunde ein anderes
theaterstück aufgeführt der eintritt
jeweils vier euro
auf der mini-bühne werden politische und
gesellschaftliche themen verhandelt das
mikro theater mit den günstigen
eintreten erfreut sich vor allem in
sparzeiten immer größerer beliebtheit
warum es gerade jetzt solche projekte
braucht erklärt mir der erfinder des
micro theaters
die wahrheit ist dass die situation in
spanien im moment ziemlich beängstigend
ist alte kürzungen im gesamten
kulturbereich von den musikstunden in
der schule über die museen bis hin zum
kino der spanische film liegt am boden
die theater sind in einer sehr prekären
situation neben der erhöhung der
mehrwertsteuer wenn es so weiter geht
werden wir bald ein land ohne
kultureinrichtungen sein und das ist das
schlimmste was passieren kann
am nächsten tag in einer seitenstraße
vor einer der größten banken spaniens
entdecke ich ein protestcamp
seid ihr schon länger hier protestiert
wenn der hypothekenkrise oder ja wir
leben hier seit 29 tagen und kämpfen
gegen die zwangsräumungen
menschen die ihre hypotheken nicht mehr
bezahlen konnten wurden auf die straße
gesetzt und mussten trotzdem weiter
zahlen
alleine im ersten halbjahr 2012 haben
spanische richter über 20.000 solche
räumungen angeordnet das hat menschen in
den suizid getrieben
wir wollen sehen welch bizarre spuren
die geplatzte immobilienblase
hinterlassen hat war denn los eine
retortenstadt im nordosten von madrid
ein symbol für den spanischen immobilien
raus
bis vor kurzem baute man in spanien
jährlich 800.000 wohnungen die nachfrage
reichte aber höchstens für die hälfte
30.000 menschen sollten einst in val de
luz leben bis jetzt sind weniger als
5.000 gekommen also baustopp
hier treffe ich rocío studierte
architektin sie machte ihre ausbildung
als die baubranche noch boomte das ist
vorbei mehr als 4000 architekten haben
allein im letzten jahr das land
verlassen ich habe eine ganze
ich habe mich vorbereitet und einen
arbeit zu haben
ich glaube dass ich habe mich gut
vorbereitet davor
und man erwartet was anders mit ich habe
stark vor etwas gekämpft
und ja ich kriege nicht davor
die 35 jährige erzählt mir dass sie sich
noch bis ende januar zeit gibt wenn sie
dann keinen job hat versucht sie im
ausland
gut ausgebildeten leute damit liebäugeln
weg zu gehen oder schon weg gegangen
sind glaubst du nicht das schadet
spanien noch mehr natürlich wir haben
eine gute öffentliche universität aber
das haben wir alle wissen deshalb haben
alle andere spanier bezahlen steuern
dass das ist ein problem wenn wir jetzt
weg fahren aber wenn kein arbeit vor uns
her gibt dann was kann ich was kann ich
machen
die krise in der branche beeinflusst
nicht nur rossius berufliches leben
sondern auch ihre privaten
entscheidungen
leichtesten gerne kinder haben sowie wie
das alles aussieht es ist schon
kompliziert daran zu denken also was
kann ich denn anbieten
zurück im pulsierenden madrid der glanz
der alten zeiten der ist noch da aber
die sozialen gegensätze die sind nicht
zu übersehen
hiervon kann aus prunkbau und nur ein
paar minuten entfernt das viertel mit
dem besetzten einkaufszentrum alec
seit einem jahr dient der ehemalige
konsum tempel als zentrum für
nachbarschaftshilfe kleidertausch eine
bibliothek mit gebrauchten büchern
privat organisierte sprachkurse im
kleinen wollen die elefanten hilfe
anbieten und sie haben eine klare
meinung wie es zu der krise kam
die spanische oligarch in diesen firmen
und banken sind entweder leute die zu
francos zeiten mit der politik
angefangen haben oder sie sind die söhne
von frank ist ischen politikern
es gab eine art pakt solange unser
lebensstandard und unser
wirtschaftlicher wohlstand stieg gab es
keine großen proteste aber jetzt geht
unser wohlstand im bach runter und
gleichzeitig haben wir keine wahre
demokratie
den leuten reicht es jetzt
spaniens gesellschaft steht vor einer
zerreißprobe
nährboden auch für extreme ansichten
leute die jetzt ins ausland gehen können
von mir aus sterben die sind mir egal
genauso wie die leute die hier bleiben
und bei mcdonald's arbeiten
sterben
elektromarkt grundsätzlich ein
sinnvolles projekt sein doch einige
äußerungen lassen mich ratlos zurück
noch am gleichen abend treffe ich irene
sie ist 29 ingenieurin und schreibt
gerade an ihrer doktorarbeit
parallel macht sie noch ein master fürs
lehramt es wird ihr dritter
studienabschluss
irene hat mich eingeladen in mehreren
kleinen wg zu übernachten wer einen tag
mit ihr verbringen will muss nämlich
früh aufstehen
was bezahlst du für dieses zimmer
ist kostet 240 euro plus
nebenkosten
das sind 40 offensive
was möchtest du bist ok
kaffee oder tee was machst du jeweils
ich
wüsste
kirchen ja
mit was du beim essen auf jeden fall
aber nicht so viel wie für andere sachen
wie rausgehen
und spaß dabei messen
normalerweise kaufe ich die sachen die
super tolle
aktion ja
ich habe gerade gekauften ich habe mich
voll gesperrt was wert aber ich dachte
ich habe vor zwei tagen gut gelaufen wir
haben diese aktion wieder wegmachen nach
der auch hätte ich
ja im moment arbeite ich nur als
larry
ich habe eine schülerin die
wir machen das so was kein ok
ich muss
einmal pro woche ungefähr einer woche
gekommen ist vielleicht 70 euro pro
monat also das einzige was ich jetzt
immer mitbekommen 60 euro ja
zum glück hat die räder ein bisschen was
gespart viel ist es nicht sie überlegt
sich gemeinsam mit ihrem freund spanien
zu verlassen vielleicht geht es nach
deutschland wo sie drei jahre studiert
hat
es ist im moment nicht ich hoffe dass
wir in bezug auf in zwei oder drei
jahren besser wird aber im moment ist
super es wenig an arbeit zu bringen
mache ich das irgendwie
traurig oder hoffnungslos
also ich muss alle sagen es gibt
manchmal wo ich sogar beine wenn ich
daran denke aber ich möchte es lieber
von man bergkamen
normalerweise versuche ich dazu
vergessen daran denken ja jemand wie es
besser
weiß auch wieso
also ich bin positiv
ich denke was
aber wird es immer schwieriger positiv
zu legen ja
irenes freund al deen holt uns ab
ich habe da fährt uns zur universität
auch er hat ingenieurwesen studiert ist
es aber arbeitslos das benzin ich finde
ihren seine eltern
irene hat ein straffes programm vor sich
und das nicht ungern die
freizeitangebote der uni sind
willkommene ablenkung und gratis dazu
erste station der
universitätschor ein ort zum durchatmen
und
weiter geht's zur pädagogik vorlesung
auch in der universität ist die krise
nicht zu übersehen
während irene über den büchern sitzt
nutze ich die zeit mein online
reisetagebuch zu schreiben
irene will nicht einfach warten auf eine
bessere zukunft sie studiert weiter um
keine zeit zu vergeuden um nicht ins
abseits zu geraten
eigentlich will irene nur eins ein ganz
normales leben wieder einem ganz normal
bezahlten teilzeitjobs damit sie die
kinder die sie sich wünscht aufwachsen
sieht
21 uhr unser letzter termin steht auf
dem programm polnisch unterricht
der polnisch unterricht wird zum ersten
mal angeboten und ist deshalb jetzt noch
gratis die nachfrage ist groß
früher kamen die polen nach spanien
heute suchen die spanier ihr glück in
polen wer weiß vielleicht bekommt die
rena als ingenieurin im aufstrebenden
polen ihre chance
was für ein tag jetzt bin ich noch in
der wohngemeinschaft von fotografin ruth
eingeladen
gemeinsam mit ihren mitbewohnern
sprechen wir über den alltäglichen kampf
gegen die krise und die spanische
mentalität sich nicht zu beklagen nach
neuen wegen zu suchen
ich glaube dass man jetzt mehr kraft
braucht um einen job zu bekommen und am
wichtigsten ist dass zufrieden und
glücklich zu sein
wenn du das hier nicht kannst dann gibt
es viele andere möglichkeiten
du kannst dir ins ausland gehen oder
wenn es dir wichtig ist hier zu bleiben
dann musst du etwas anderes machen du
musst deine prioritäten setzen und dafür
kämpfen
gut bleibt optimistisch sie hat
unterstützung und sie hat ihre freunde
am tag der abreise
welch ein letztes mal über die projekte
des soul
ich denke über spanien nach und über
diese woche mit der so genannten
verlorenen generation
viele von ihnen werden momentan
ausgebremst ja aber da ist auch die
lebensfreude die flexibilität der
soziale rückhalt und der unbändige wille
aus der misere wieder herauszukommen
ich frage mich was hier mehr mut braucht
bleiben
oder gehen